c'est beau fils thibault il fait beau il
fait beau je vais aller acheter une
feuille de papier pour écrire à ma
cousine re la lie ouais bon casimir
qu'est-ce que tu ne dis pas bonjour au
françois
excuse moi mais tu sais je pensais
tellement à la feuille de papier que je
dois aller acheter que je ne t'avais
même pas vu mais je ne me fâche pas que
j'aime et c'est cela m'arrive à moi
aussi d'être tellement plongé dans mes
pensées que je ne vois pas les gens que
je croise ah bon ça t'arrive à toi aussi
mais oui casimir ça arrive même à tout
le monde
c'est pourquoi il faut faire très
attention avant de se fâcher contre
quelqu'un qui vous a croisé 100
milliards bonjour réflexe chinois il
faut que je me dépêche je veux que la
nette pour ma cousine ou laly partent ce
soir il faut que j'aille acheter la
feuille tout de suite à l'accord dépêche
toi casimir ai fait mes amitiés d'accord
tout à l'heure ça me joly je vais
acheter une feuille de papier pour
écrire ma cousine marie françois rené me
tient très nettoyer des accessoires de
cloud oui je crois que le clown pique
nique co va nous faire une petite visite
un séjour qui a pris d'autres options
c'est une surprise m'a dit moselle ou
lit très bien je n'insiste pas lui
casimir ça semble grave allons-y julie
vient pour en monter les marches il
fallait redouté souffler et laisser
parler sa scène de grave il il ya oui ou
quasiment là dans le bois ne t'en fais
pas casimir leur esprit libre je vais
tirer son coup mais que ce gros matou il
est malade
- est-ce qu'il ya un gros matou surcroît
qu'il sèche
bonjour madame ou mademoiselle je me
présente et de mes chutes
bonjour et moselle moi je m'appelle
françois excusez moi mais je n'aime pas
les poignées de main vous avez tout à
fait raison d'un gros sel
bonsoir c'était je la reconnais c'est la
voix le voit une voleuse mais vous allez
voir me de ce que petite [ __ ] rond je
vais vous d'écraser un minuscule plus on
jette encore toi expliquons-nous
calmement s'il vous plaît casimir dis
nous ce que tu as fait et bien je
traversais le bois lorsque j'ai vu cette
dame qui volait des feuilles sur
toulouse arbres à casimir ce n'est pas
un vol très grave
enfin mademoiselle fit est à vous la
parole
voilà je suis fataliste et je suis
chargée de compter combien d'espèces
d'un où il ya sur l'île aux enfants
aussi pour être sûr de ne pas me tromper
et bien je prends une feuille sur chacun
mais bien tu vois quasiment il faut
toujours se méfier avant d'accuser
quelqu'un
excusez moi mademoiselle s'est tourné
des séquences où l'attend maintenant
qu'il est surtout pas à excuse-moi
casimir j'ai pas eu le temps de prévenir
mais
mademoiselle futaie n'aime pas du tout
les poignées de mains je sens qu'ils ont
mais je ne voulais pas faire de monassut
mignon petit canard mademoiselle je dois
vous dire quand je ne suis pas un gros
matou ni à petit pucerons ni un gros
canard je suis un gros monstre devient
télé via mon petit lapin c'est une
excellente idée
attendez mademoiselle j'appelle les
enfants ils vont nous aider les enfants
venez nous allons faire un jeu nous
allons faire un jeu avec mademoiselle
ennemis futé venez vite
mademoiselle est nécessaire je viens de
ramasser les feuilles d'art dans le wadi
nos enfants alors nous allons essayer de
trouver les noms des arbres auxquels les
appartiennent d'accord et vous si chez
vous vous cherchez avec lio est bien
mademoiselle futaie montrez nous vos
feuilles ouest
elles sont tout cas c'est mon frère
bah oui cela devait arriver dès conquis
les feuilles des arbres elle casse
rapidement heureusement j y ai pensé et
je sais une copie de chaque nouvel
habillage et bien commençons par les
véritables feuilles moselle
regardez les enfants de quel arbre non
c'est pas que vous étiez c'est un sapeur
c'est un peu voyant ce qu'il ya dans la
collection de mademoiselle schuiten
celle ci est ce que c'est c'est un chêne
c'est un platane j'espère que chez eux
coin nos amis cherchent aussi à celle ci
une feuille de shining très bien
véronique et celle ci c'est d'une
feuille de marronniers très bien
mademoiselle futaie montrez-moi les
feuilles que vous avez dessiné
merci celle ci les enfants dessinent et
bien c'est une feuilles de frêne elle et
elle n'est ce pas ensuite qu'à dessiner
mademoiselle futaie voisine de
noirmoutier mais non c'est pas inquiet
c'est un chat tuning à oui c'est très
bien la peine qu'a donné la bonne
réponse
j'aime bien les châtaignes cette feuille
c'est une feuille de non c'est pas une
feuille de challans c'est une feuilles
de tilleul et jolie n'est ce pas les
signes bien de nos activités et enfin la
dernière personne de pain très bien
c'était ma feuille de salaire et bien
voilà il ya voilà vous avez vu toute ma
collection
mademoiselle futaie vous avez une très
belle collection je voulais vous
demander mademoiselle [ __ ] ça vous
ennuie pas de me donner cette grande
foule à lui tendue toujours là mon petit
poussin
merci quand même
que va t on faire de cette feuille aux
biens françois je n'ai pas eu le temps
d'aller acheter une feuille de papier
alors je vais écrire sur cette feuille
est envoyé la lettre à ma cousine au
mali